from exciting blockbusters to
thought-provoking Indies 2017 was a
great year for films and while audiences
saw no shortage of great moments on the
big screen plenty of quality scenes
ended up on the cutting room floor here
are the best deleted scenes that you
probably missed in 2017
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 Peter
quill may have saved the galaxy a few
times but that doesn't make him an
expert on earths more primitive
technology this deleted scene from
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 shows our
intergalactic hero trying to figure out
how to work a Zune Krag Lin played by
Sean Gunn offers up some rather choice
musical opinions Thin Lizzy is a group I
like a lot there's a lady on there named
Alice Cooper that I liked a lot she
seems kind of angry but kind of like
stuff we felt we're kids you know it
makes sense that this slow scene would
be cut from the action heavy outing but
this funny character moment is still a
must see Beauty and the Beast one of the
more bizarre plot points in Disney's
live-action Beauty and the Beast has to
do with the castle staff who have all
been turned into household items because
of a curse a deleted scene from the
recent live-action remake of the film
reveals what happened to one of the
castles lesser servants we first meet
the unfortunately named Monsieur
toilette when Josh GAD Lefou is scared
away by his gurgling voice in a deleted
scene after the curse has been broken
Lefou notices a dirty disheveled man who
smells rather familiar so what are you
gonna do now
brush my teeth disgusting but also very
funny
especially for fans of toilet humor
spider-man homecoming
even though fresh-faced Tom Holland was
outstanding as Peter Parker some comic
fans were hoping to see someone else
under the mask and spider-man homecoming
namely Miles Morales the fan favorite
comic book character who became the
spider-man of Marvel's Ultimate Universe
in homecoming donald glover plays Aaron
Davis who is Miles uncle in comics hey
that's gonna dissolve in two hours no no
no come fix this two hours you deserve
that I got ice cream you're a criminal
well he merely hints at having a nephew
that theatrical cut Davis actually calls
him by name in an awesome deleted scene
after spider-man webs his hand to his
car
Aaron unable to release himself
eventually gives in and calls his nephew
yes sorry miles I'm not gonna make it
yeah I'm just stuck
although it's just a small reference it
was more than enough to send comic book
fans into a tizzy thor ragnarok the Hulk
punching Thor was one of the most
memorable moments from The Avengers and
Thor Ragnarok almost included a callback
to the scene as the team returned to
Asgard The Hulk was originally supposed
to punch Loki out of the frame Loki
bloke Loki's alive you believe it he's
like he's up there considering what
happened the last time these two
characters saw each other
it would have been a hilarious for union
director Tyco ytt
revealed in an interview with Empire
that the much-loved moment had to be cut
for time so many little things that yeah
we just had to get rid of for time and
just you know sometimes it's just like
we'll have to choose a bit between that
and banner falling on the bridge for the
big laugh there are still plenty of
other hilarious moments in Thor Ragnarok
but an Avengers callback that also cut
Loki down to size would have been a fun
addition fingers crossed that it winds
up on the DVD get out while Rose is
clearly a villain in the film get out
when deleted scene may make you question
everything you thought you knew about
her when Chris played by Daniel Kaluga
describes the sunken place to her bros
reveals that she too has had a similar
experience I had the same thing she
hypnotized me when I was in high school
first stage fright and I had the
craziest nightmares but I just remember
thinking worked Rose easily could have
been lying to keep Chris calm but it
raises the possibility that she could
also have been hypnotized into
cooperating with her family's evil plan
considering how it distracts from the
film's message and shows a truly evil
character in a sympathetic new light
it's easy to see why the scene was cut
still it's interesting to consider the
new questions that would have raised if
it had been kept in the film Logan there
were so many deaths in Logan that some
characters like Stephen Merchant
Caliban didn't even get to die on screen
a deleted scene however actually shows
the emotional demise of this fan
favorite character
on the movies blu-ray commentary
director James Mangal
explained that while he felt bad for
cutting the scene he didn't want to call
into question why Logan didn't just take
calla band's body with him like he did
for Professor X although the movie was
plenty bleak without an additional death
scene it would have been nice to have
closure for such an important character
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales it may not have reached the
seafaring heights of the franchise's
previous films but pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell no tales was an
undeniably fun addition to the saga of
Jack Sparrow this is most apparent in a
deleted scene where Johnny Depp's
freewheeling pirate finds himself at
odds with Henry the son of Will Turner
I saw her ankles you've just seen it a
lot more if you kept your cakehole shot
the clip begins with Henry's threatening
Jack to help him break his father's
curse in return
Jack helpfully offers the boys some
advice on how to hold his sword before
demanding to be run through your first
murder happy to be a partner just don't
mind all the blood and the bulging
eyeballs and such of course have you no
intention of actually letting Henry kill
him Jack pulls a gun on him luckily for
audiences both characters got the chance
to live another day on the high seas The
Breakfast Club it's been more than 30
years since The Breakfast Club hit
theatres but fans of the original
teenage misfits were treated to a
deleted scene thanks to the film's 2017
criterion collection deluxe reissue the
sequence kicks off in the girls bathroom
with Molly Ringwald's Claire expressing
confusion about Ally's shiva's Alison in
her particular cleanliness habits you
wash your hands feet leave food inches
away from a live toilet
I'm sorry I don't want it to press you
Allison stays predictably silent and
then deliberately drops a potato chip in
the sink before popping it into her
mouth although the scene doesn't amount
to much
it's a welcome and fun interaction
between two classic characters it's not
correct thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out this other cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]